[Musique]
l'actualité nous le permet prenons le
temps ce n'est pas si souvent de se
payer une bonne tranche de rire avec ce
one woman show de maria pacôme au
théâtre de la gaîté montparnasse
cet appareil la comédienne fait ses
adieux paraît-il à la scène avec un
spectacle intitulé l'éloge de ma paresse
sophie jovial moines désarmante et drôle
revoilà maria pacôme
l'actrice a repris la plume pour se
livrer toute entière mais elle l'a sûr
c'est son dernier tour de piste
je ne vais plus faire de théâtre j'en ai
fait j'en ai fait j'en ai fait je veux
plus je j'ai dû me ce qui la motive
c'est son cher théâtre des dizaines de
pièces dont 8 qu'elle a écrite elle même
cette fois ci c'est l'éloge de ma
paresse pour laquelle elle a travaillé
du jour les autres voient les étals je
me sens paresseux
d'ailleurs je me sens jamais responsable
c'est toujours les autres la baisse de
mauvaise foi qu'elle a perpétuellement
c'est pas facile d'être paresseuse comme
je le suis sans me vautrer sans être
quelqu'un qui traînent en égard à non
voilà j'ai fait de la paresse un art je
vous demande souvent à ma cousine
combien de son ennui mais quel âge elle
a en ce moment à part des choses
intéressantes mais quel âge là
ont-ils eu en une fleur sur scène c'est
pourquoi a atteint je m'en souviens je
croyais pourtant ça ne date pas d'hier
ses débuts de fofolle excentrique avec
lefebvre ou de funès c'est pour échapper
cette image qu'elle a écrit sa première
pièce apprends-moi céline avec le tout
jeune daniel auteuil
c'était pas ma meilleure pub jamais
touristes et ma meilleure pièce est
celle qui a eu vraiment débordements et
ce qui m'a le plus touchée on a fêté le
canard enchaîné je crois je sais plus
quel journal avait dit écoutez c'est
n'importe quoi mais surtout le ratez pas
ces lois la poule et les deux cas qu'est
ce que j'aurais aimé monter les marches
à cannes moi j'ai dîné avec une jeune
femme charmante ravissante vraiment une
jolie brune mais qui visiblement cet
excès gonfler les lèvres et j'ai résisté
à leur envie de lui dire ne sortait pas
comme ça mais tu es un slip
la nuit je vais j'ai un gros paquet
angoisse l'âge du monde du monde du jeu
mourir moi je vis je me donnais un coup
de pelle et j'enfile une culotte pour
moi me retrouve correct
et comme c'est bien connu une actrice
n'a que l'âge de ses succès ça nous
laisse encore de belles années avec elle
c'est un numéro quoi
[Musique]